on ne sait quelles que soient les
milieux les femmes perçoivent en moyenne
un salaire inférieur aux hommes je pense
malheureusement que ça va encore durer
un petit peu le football n'échappe pas à
cette règle alors que l'euro féminin
devrait se dérouler en angleterre du 6
au 31 juillet prochain le journal
l'équipe nous révèle les primes des
vainqueurs ou plutôt des vainqueurs
c'est confidentiel
2,08 millions d'euros à se partager pour
l'équipe qui remportera la compétition
soit un peu plus de 20000 euros chacune
une somme bien inférieure à celle des
hommes qui toucherait presque deux fois
plus en cas de victoire à l'euro même si
l'euro féminin rapporte moins d'argent
les différences de salaires sont
considérables alors êtes vous choqué par
les primes des joueuses de l'équipe de
france
alors êtes vous choqué par les primes
des joueuses de l'équipe de france oui
non oui non oui non ne se prononcent pas
c'est le fils de daniel derrière
ce qui se passe quoi ton micro parti
avait un peu d'eau dessus mais rien je
me suis lamentablement verser de l'eau
[Rires]
c'est la mode fait attention à toi
mais bon déroulement des missions
c'est franchement la honte sur le foot
et tout vient de l'uefa l'uefa ceolin ce
nom se ruaient d'agréger tous à jarlard
l'uefa y verse pour l'italie l'année
dernière qui a gagné l'euro
28,5 millions d'accord et pour les
gammes féminines on les aura pour les
hommes mais voilà et pour l'équipe
féminine qui gagnera l'euro 2 millions
0,8 d'euros 2 millions d'euros 14 fois
moins donc c'est la honte
c'est incroyable c'est du sexisme du
machisme les femmes disputent le
football maintenant exactement comme les
hommes c'est aussi beau les gens adorent
et franchement moi ça me moi qui adore
le foot je suis dégoûté
sur le fait que les parts des femmes les
femmes jouent au foot comme les garçons
et c'est de mieux en mieux il ya moins
de risque et pour la gare - depuis
science il ya moins de puissance et il
ya moins de monde ça génère moins
d'argent au niveau des sponsors c'est
sale et les projets tout le monde veut
pas renier question est bien pour la
main je réfléchis
on avait des cette augmentation c'est
peut-être trop trop vite et blanc
mais moi je suis moi je voudrais que les
femmes comme les hommes mais c'est pas
possible pour l'instant et on y vient
mais pour l'instant voilà impossible on
y vient les stars sont les stats sont
plus en plus remplie gens sur w9 ça fait
beaucoup d'audience avec mon ami xavier
d'homère qui commente les matchs ça fait
1 millions 5,1 millions 6 c'est très
bien comme audiences mais on y vient
tout doucement ça fait pas 12 millions à
la télé le foot exactement vous avez dit
moi croient question je vous avais dit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
laugnac il a plus
tard servait même si j'attaque de
phrases sont pas les
centrales pendant la pub ses conseils
alors ça y est vous l'avez trouvé votre
fou
il dit n'importe quoi c'est pas du
sexisme gratuit c'est une réalité
économique oui le foot féminin ça marche
mieux on s'y intéresse on s'y intéresse
un peu plus mais ça sent fois moins
d'impact que le foot masculin je vous
mets au défi autour de cette table à
part jamais c'est la fin du set malgré
deux de ses cinq noms de deux joueuses
de ligue mais france 3 je les adore
voilà et là où c'est pas du sexuel il ya
d'autres métiers par exemple dans les
nouveaux métiers les influenceurs et ben
les femmes sont beaucoup plus payées que
les hommes c'est la nature du métier qui
veut ça et là c'est la même chose c'est
une réalité économique en aucun cas du
sexisme les mannequins femmes ont
toujours est alors il
sait mettre une petite cagnotte pour
compenser le salaire puisqu'il trouve ça
tellement
ce qui qui trouve sa voie celle réalité
c'est un business il ya des sports qui
évolue comme le tennis genou ça va dire
à l'américaine
je ne peux pas répondre il ya des
joueurs qui évoluent mais parce que
c'est n'importe quoi crash mondial mais
c'est faux c'est faux c'est
le foot féminin
qui dit n'importe quoi non c'est non
mais valérie a raison même pas du tout
syrie il faut des gestes regarder en
tennis on pourrait dire c'est pas le
même style c'est par ici
sont achetés et on achète les femmes et
les hommes en même temps donc ça n'a
rien à voir et puis les les matches
voilà quand on est en stade il ya des
matchs féminins il ya des matchs
masculins ça n'a rien à voir sa femme
s'est plaint les femmes s'est plaint les
stades
voile est pas plaint tu sais très bien
et revient il ya des stades mille
personnes et à des stades de ligue 1
d arkema ca 2000 personnes alors on a vu
un beau truc et l'egypte d'où fait mais
on a vu un bon match de foot féminin en
général comprend pas que de l'équipe de
france est en train de bouger on a vu un
pglyon quarante mille personnes au parc
des princes sur canal+ à 20h30 les
choses elle bouge ça peut arriver du
jour au lendemain il ya dix ans personne
s'intéresse le féminin comment
sa vie a
changé
[Applaudissements]
sanary
pouvoir à tous il a changé et là il a
cité canal+ comme ça et si nice est bien
dans le groupe c l'allemagne 10,2 matin
avec le salaire que je vais prendre ça
veut dire qu'elle accuse voilà sur canal
plus quarante mille personnes
travaillent chez eux alors je vous le
dis c'est ça le problème que j'ai c'est
quand on gagne plus on suce plus est
celle impressionnèrent
sérieux des intentions attentes et c'est
lyon c'était
avec les équipes de babouche à toi
t'aurais pas dit ça à bras
avec les équipes de thierry cheleman
exactement maxime
[Applaudissements]
mais il se bat pour le fou de ces
derniers
modèles et fort il est très beau il est
énormément sur l'équipe
non parce que ma maman il et voilà on va
leur laisser sur les sémaphores de 2
voilà c'est beaucoup d'émotions mais tu
comprends qu'on puisse pas faire
l'égalité salariale hubert le brenn oui
c'est à toi que je parle oui c'est toi
qui parle six heures numéro un tu peux
tu peux bien imaginer qu'on peut pas
faire l'égalité salariale par rapport au
barça mais c'est toi tu parles de choses
tu n'as même pas étudié le dossier et il
manque un tue les trois conneries
ça fait 30 ans que ça
vient de poster hope a pas de salaire
mais de prime bosse un peu tes dossiers
pour les clés toi comme castaldi
si vous avez remarqué moi qui passait là
y'avait cassany prend toujours
[Rires]
dans la ville il a toujours un temps
fort cash et
c'est vrai non mais sans déconner mais
c'est très intelligent si bien dire on
se compare pas de salaire on parle de
près on dit mais bon poids raymond
la raison des primes plus puisque c'est
pas de salaire qu'on parle on parle de
primes vingt mille euros c'est vrai que
c'est pas beaucoup pour le foot féminin
par rapport à ce que ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ne donne
je salue maurice
barrès avoir aidé vincent plus jamais ça
va être content que je
te dis la vérité dans des sables
mouvants